You know, what I don't get is this, you know what? I don't get dude, this,
this reclining seat argument,
this reclining seat argument where the video went viral.
I tweeted it when the dude was the lady reclined seat and the has ho
dude behind her was like punching the back of her seat
because he thought it was disrespectful that she reclined the seat.
Dude was just trying to watch videos on his phone. Hey dude, you're a, man.
It to see reclines, let it recline Johnnie Cochran.
If the CBRE class let them recline, but dude let it recline, man.
The seat reclines and the guy's like, Oh yeah, yeah. I don't know people.
I can't believe there's people out there that actually are like, no,
it's disrespectful to recline your seat, bro. I paid for it.
Also the seat reclines.
I'm not rejiggering the seat to make it recline it reclines. Therefore,
if my seat goes to your tank, swear to God,
don't take it up with Delta, man.
This is a my problem. Yeah. How about this?
Check in and get a better seats to your seat.
Reclines to the guys all in the back wall, bro.
Just because you're in competence doesn't mean she shouldn't be comfortable.
that. I cannot believe this has.
Dude is trying to watch what is he trying to watch some movie on his,
on his privileged iPhone. And he's just bumping her head like that in front.
The lady is like 50 years old. This guy's younger than me.
If you can believe that. And this guy, what a dude,
of course he's got just a beard too. And a bald head. Those guys are the most, a
DNO or the most submits guy is a guy who's got hair this long
and, and a completely shaved face and it's jelled and there's one little piece
coming forward, you know? Oh he roses. You know what he does?
He rolls his, um, uh, sleeves up like this.
He does it like this, like against his, the side.
That's so, dude, that he's doing that. And it makes me angry. And I want to,
I want to live with that girl and take care of her,
even though she's older than me,
because that's so insane and insensitive to do that. That guy's a ho
like let her recline, she paid for it.
Wow dude. And I can't stop thinking about when Peter Pablo says,
eh, and I say Heineken because I love it. I love it.
And they pay me for it in his song. Cool. How I keep thinking about that.
But um, yeah dude, that's so insane.
And so also when I, you don't understand, man,
when I'm, and this happens rarely because I check and also,
you know, now bags bags. Of course I fly first class,
but you know,
when I was in the back back and somebody goes and reclines into my chest
region, guess what? There we go. I'm dealing with something.
That's all that's happening.
I'm relaxing as best I can with someone's face in my,
in my chest. I'll give him a massage dude. Cause I up and I know it and great.
I'll make the best of a bad situation. I up. I'll give him a scalp massage.
I'll put my feet over there, you know,
torso and give them a scalp massage.
Like I'm some monkey on their back helping out because dude, you up,
you got the last seat. You don't have to get the last seat.
Airline F everything about flying is uncomfortable, everything.
So just suck it up.
You think we want to be here 30,000 feet in the air? If yeah,
I don't get it. I don't get, I don't like when people are disrespectful,
I don't get how people think that the reclining,
the seat thing is disrespectful. And you know what?
I don't want to hear any of it anymore. I don't want to hear anybody being like,
well, let's consider it too. No, dude. It is not. It is considerate.
It's actually considered to not fly. How about that drive?
When someone reclines, when I,
when I reclined all the way back and it goes into somebody's lap, if I,
I hope it goes back far enough to where I could open my eyes and see them upside
down. And then I want to say, you're welcome.
I'm being respectful because this is what I want to do.
And we're all in this together. One time I was on the plane.
One time I was, uh, I was, uh,
on the plane and this guy I like was trying to turn my TV on and I was hitting
the button on the TV, in front of it, you know, the headrest in front of it.
And the guy turns around and he says, this is my seat. That's yours.
And I was like, bro,
it's crazy how people just go zero to 60 when they're in public,
like already off about their situation.
Nah, you don't need to be like that. I'll go like that. Nah,
you don't need to be like that. Why are you telling me that sir?
People were saying that Europeans don't recline seats, which is stupid, dude.
I see them British too. It's just like, Oh the way back home. Right?
People were saying British. Oh yeah, Europeans. They don't recline seats.
So why? Because they respect bro. No way. Yeah.
Elite British people respect. But bro, have you seen
[inaudible]? I was sitting on my seat all the way back into your penis.
That's what I'll do. And I'll start sucking it. I'm not even gay. it.
I don't care. I've got to keep my mouth busy on his flight. Go quicker. Yeah.
RA I don't care. Oh, we clone all the way back to Hormel.
I don't know if there's a guy or a girl behind me.
Hopefully it is a go because they're not paid no deepened.
Some wet top does a penis. I'll just use it as a pillow.
Hopefully it ain't odd. Jacob. We're Miranda a little bit. Bose.
I don't know if I like to put my bow. My head. Yeah.
You didn't use one of your bows or your NAB. I swung on me. see
it's one of my pillows. You got a Chodo. Yeah.
I hope you got a cause here we go. We,
those British guys. Don't, man.
You seen Europeans bro.